[Applaudissements]
négocié dans des situations complexes
négocier dans des situations de crise
négociée dans des environnements dans
lesquels on doit faire face à du risque
à de l'humain en situation dégradée
eh bien ça a été mon métier pendant un
certain nombre d'années mais pour tout
vous dire quand j'ai commencé dans ce
métier là ce qui m'intéressait c'était
l'équipe d'intervention
c'était le groupe dassault c'est ce
qu'on voit à la télévision dans les
films dans les séries la cagoule la
tenue noire les armes et je voulais
participer à la reddition de forcené au
sauvetage d'otages en participant à la
section d'intervention la négociation
pour moi c'était assez éloignées et
d'ailleurs j'ai suivi un cursus assez
classique 1 pour passer mon concours
d'officier j'ai fait des études de droit
j'ai fait sciences po mon mémoire de
sciences po c'était la coordination de
la lutte antiterroriste en europe dont
j'étais déjà très axé sur le sujet j'ai
passé mon concours d'officier je suis
sorti bien classés j'ai choisi en poste
en section d'intervention pour préparer
les tests du raid et un jour en
commandant du raid qui s'appelle michel
marie vient me voir et me dit voilà je
sais que tu candidate pour passer les
tests
moi je suis prête récupérer au sein du
raid mais pas pour l'intervention
je prête récupérer pour faire de la
négociation alors quand vous avez en
tête
le groupe dassault des casques cagoulés
descente en rappel
et quand on vous parle de négociations
première méthode qui vient à l'esprit
c'est bruce willis ben johnson kevin
dyson
c'est à dire que la négociation on avait
l'idée que c'était quelque chose qui
était plutôt du rapport de force
on a les intimés à l'autre l'ordre de se
rendre en lui expliquant que c'était
préférable pour lui on a essayé de
développer ce métier de manière un peu
différente
dire qu'on est allé chercher de la deûle
expertise de la connaissance j'ai eu la
chance de me former à l'académie du
réveil j'ai rencontré les négociateurs
en afrique du sud des négociateurs à
scotland yard et on a réussi à
structurer ce métier pour en faire un un
vrai métier et faire de cette structure
cette organisation une façon de négocier
un monde meilleur
alors cette image de négociation c'est
vrai que quand on voit ces situations de
crise on se dit que la négociation est
vraiment quelque chose qui se fait au
dernier moment alors que tout à fait au
contraire la négociation la première
chose qu'on va mettre en place
et quand on a commencé ce métier de
manière un peu empirique on avait 30 %
de réussite 30% les opérations était
réglé par la négociation
quand je dirais que c'est bien on a
monté tout doucement l'équipe en
compétences pour au début des années
2000 arrivé à 81 5 % de réussite on a
presque triplé
l'efficacité de la négociation et on
pouvait résoudre de manière pacifique
des situations de crise dans lesquels
normalement on aurait eu intervenir par
la force
et là je me suis dit c'est intéressant
ce métier de négociateur peut-être que
on peut aussi l'amener sur d'autres
situations et je me suis intéressé au
problème des kidnappings des
ressortissants français kidnappés
comment on faisait pour négocier pour
les récupérer est ce qu avait une équipe
spécialisée hes qui avait une
méthodologie
j'ai commencé à structurer une approche
pour cette problématique là et là aussi
on a eu un taux de succès assez étonnant
dans la gestion des kidnappings et c'est
qu'ils n'appliqueront on allait prêter
main forte à des entreprises parce que
souvent les personnes kidnappées c'est
aider les collaborateurs qui étaient en
mission dans les pays sensibles
le nigéria le mexique l'afghanistan et
on allait les sortir par la négociation
alors ces entreprises qui nous ont vu
fonctionner on dit mais pas mal votre
méthode de négociation là est ce qu'on
pourrait pas nous l'utiliser dans nos
propres situation de négociation et on
s'est dit tiens pourquoi pas est ce
qu'on pourrait voir comment on pourrait
collaborer et on a commencé à travailler
avec des entreprises sur leurs
négociations
alors au début des négociations sous
tension des négociations difficiles les
gros contentieux
puis des négociations sociales et puis
des négociations commerciales et on
s'est aperçu qu'en fait à part les
enjeux c'était exactement les mêmes
questions qu'ils devaient se poser dans
leur situation de négociation
alors on s'est dit qu'on allait
transmettre on allait transmettre à m
pourquoi je vous dit on j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer un négociateur
professionnels qui s'appelle marouane
mairie qui est devenu mon binôme en
négociation un des meilleurs
négociateurs que je connaisse m
lui venait du monde de l'entreprise et
de normand très éloignées on s'est dit
qu'on devait mettre en place une
méthodologie qui pouvait permettre à
chacun dans son quotidien quel que soit
son métier de négocier et on a créé un
référentiel qui s'appelle pacifique at
pacifique est parce qu on cherche à
pacifier les situations pacifier les
relations interpersonnelles pacifier les
situations entre les organisations
avec le temps ce référentiel a commencé
à se diffuser à être transmis
aujourd'hui les diplomates de l'onu
utilise ce référentiel aujourd'hui des
drh utilisent ce référentiel pour
résoudre des négociations complexes de
manière efficace et faire en sorte que
tout le monde gagne à la fin
que tout le monde obtienne ce qui est
juste pour lui ça peut vous paraître
étonnant mais on est devenu le premier
réseau mondial de négociateurs
professionnels nous les petits français
on a pris la main sur ce métier là et on
a aujourd'hui des négociateurs anglo
saxons des négociateurs asiatiques qui
viennent s'intéresser à passer des caps
comme ils disent
comment on peut pacifier les relations
comment on peut mettre de l'humain dans
des situations où on est souvent en
compétition et là on leur parle d'
empathie on leur parle de création du
lien création de la relation confiance
on a la venue aujourd'hui à développer
des transmission du savoir en
négociation dans des métiers on
n'imaginait pas qu'on pourrait le faire
la médecine
pourquoi il ya un phénomène qu'on
appelle la non observance la non
observance c'est le fait pour un patient
de ne pas prendre son traitement
correctement la non-adhésion du patient
il ya des pathologies pathologies
chroniques
le sclérose en plaques le diabète
l'hypertension dans lesquels les
patients ne prennent pas correctement
leur traitement jusqu'à 80 % des
patients et ça a été ma première
expérience dans le monde de la médecine
un médecin qui va me voir à l'issue
d'une conférence que je fais dans une
organisation en école de commerce il
avoir une vie est ce que tu peux m'aider
sur les négociations
je t'écoute moi je sais pas qu'est ce
que tu fais comme négociation quelle est
ton métier unis je suis pédiatre je
traite la mucoviscidose 70 % des
adolescents que je traite ne prennent
pas leur traitement
ce que c'est de la négociation et on lui
a dit bien sûr c'est de la négociation
pourquoi parce qu'on ne peut rien
imposer à un patient on doit négocier
avec lui et on a réussi en travaillant
avec lui à descendre l'inde en observant
ce à moins de 30% alors ça reste encore
énorme 30% mais par ses techniques de
négociation par les bonnes questions que
l'on se pose la création du lien on peut
stabiliser ce type de situation alors
voyons vient de loin le monde de la
prise d'otages du kidnapping le monde de
l'entreprise négociations sociales
commerciales aujourd'hui la relation
patient la diplomatie tout le monde
passe sa vie à négocier tout le monde
passe sa vie à négocier pourtant tout le
monde n'est pas forcément formés à la
négociation
alors on a lancé une initiative
parce qu'on a une ambition qui peut vous
paraître un peu étonnante on veut
changer le monde par la négociation
vraiment et nous avons monté une
fondation qui s'appelle à diane gibbs a
day keeps qu'est ce que c'est c'est
apprendre aux enfants à négocier
pourquoi pour éviter les situations de
violence et de harcèlement
les cours de récréation sont souvent des
lieux de violence de violences physiques
de violence psychologique
quand j'étais étudiant j'ai été jetée
pions j'étais surveillants et je voyais
la violence la santé aujourd'hui j'ai
quatre enfants donc je vois ce qui se
passe dans les écoles et on s'aperçoit
que très souvent dans les situations de
désaccord dans des situations de conflit
eh bien on en vient aux mains on en
vient à crier on en vient à laisser
éclater nos émotions
alors on explique aux enfants que les
émotions c'est super c'est très bien
elles sont légitimes elles sont
efficaces mais on leur explique surtout
que le conflit dans le sens d'un
désaccord exprimé le conflit ça peut
être quelque chose de bien
pourquoi le conflit ça permet de créer
de la valeur ajoutée
le conflit c'est quand je dis à l'autre
que je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui et
si a pas de conflit a pas de création de
valeur imaginez je vous donne une idée
vous êtes tous d'accord avec moi c'est
nul on n'a qu'une idée à nous tous
création de valeur zéro et encore pire
je vous donne une idée personne n'est
d'accord avec moi mais personne n'ose me
le dire c'est encore plus nul parce
qu'on a toujours aucune idée je me prive
de votre vision qui pourrait alimenter
la mienne et vous êtes frustrés de ne
pas m'avoir dit que vous n'étiez pas
d'accord
l'expression du désaccord c'est ce qui
crée la valeur à condition d'utiliser la
négociation pour faire en sorte que
chacun construit dix obtiennent ce qui
est juste pour lui et en école primaire
au sein d' adn qu'ils sont fait
l'exercice
l'exercice du sis on a fait imprimer les
grandes affiches avec 1,6 dessus on
déroule la fiche au milieu de la salle
de classe
on met une partie des élèves d'un côté
et une partie des élèves de l'autre on
va voir les élèves qui sont là et on
leur dit expliquez-leur que c'est 1,6 si
on vend les élèves qui sont là et on
leur dit expliquer leur que c'est un
neuf et on laisse faire et en 30
secondes
c'est la guerre atomique cc6 on arrête
le tir stop arrêtez le jeu fait le tour
pour voir
ils font le tour il faut bien oui c'est
vrai quatre ans mais là oui c'est 1,6
voyez c'est pas un oeuf ou 1,6 c'est un
oeuf et 1,6 et avec 1 906 qu'est ce
qu'on fait un afflux 6,9 fois 6 9/10 et
par 6 c'est parce que vous avez tous les
deux raison et que vous entendez tous
les deux le point de vue de l'autre que
vous êtes capables de créer de la valeur
ajoutée et ça techniquement comment ça
s'appelle s'appelle l'assertivité
défendre son point de vue en acceptant
celui de l'autre
ces deux-là certificat alors tout à
l'heure je parlais des motions
d'empathie maintenant je parle
l'assertivité sont souvent de thèmes
qu'on oppose empathie et assertivité
sont les deux jambes sur lesquels va
s'appuyer une négociatrice ou un
négociateur
on doit être à la fois empathique voir
l'émotion de l'autre elle accepté tout
en étant assertif défendre son point de
vue en acceptant que l'autre puisse
aussi défendre le cyan et cette notion
de négociations on essaie aujourd'hui de
la poussée avec un label on a créé une
ong qui s'appelle négo for good pourquoi
parce que on pense qu'en négociant de
manière éthique et responsable au delà
du fait que ça correspond aux standards
des valeurs que nous défendons et bien
le business et plus efficaces et les
entreprises des organisations qui
participent avec nous un ego for good
qui défendent les principes de la
négociation éthique et responsable et
bien s'aperçoivent que leur business il
est plus efficaces qu'elles maintiennent
leurs marges qu'elle ne développe que
leurs collaborateurs sont satisfaits du
travail qu'ils font alors cette création
de valeur ajoutée
cette utilisation de la négociation bien
ça repose aussi sur vous sur nous on est
tous amenés à négocier
donc la prochaine fois que vous allez
négocier pensez-y négocier pour un monde
meilleur
n'utilisez la négociation que si l
éthique et responsable et vous verrez
qu'avec tout ça on change le monde
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]